[Music]
today i'm taking my queue from italy
a country that takes home cooking family
and fresh vibrant flavors extremely
seriously the italians are brilliantly
using good food to bring people together
as well as being delicious today's
dishes are also really quick and easy to
make
leaving you more time to sit down and
enjoy them with your friends and family
first up in my ultimate italian food
a deliciously tasty breakfast of fennel
sausage frittata
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible
next a lunch to whisk your way to italy
in the first fork fall grilled sardines
with gremolata and also pasta salad
fresh
clean almost if we're sat on the amalfi
coast
and as boys join forces as jack helps me
cook an incredible dinner with dishes
from the length and breath of
[Music]
a italy from the south quick thick jam
crostini with creamy burrata
from the north a hearty slow-cooked beef
cheek ragu with paprika deli
well when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day just tell her where
you got the recipe for morning promise
promise
rounding off with a tuscan inspired
dessert luxurious espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle maggie
how is it done it's so tasty
follow these ultimate recipes and you
too can embrace breakfast lunch and
dinner the passionate italian way
starting with breakfast a fennel sausage
frittata
[Music]
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata
is in the sausage
nice hot pan onions in
generous on the onions heat
nice and high
season
fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor
everyone's used to cooking sausages
whole
but it's a really nice way of
using them take them out of their thin
skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high
and the longer you caramelise the
sausage the more flavor
you're going to gain
six
whole eggs
give your eggs a really good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
when you fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage
gonna make it even more italian by
topping it
with some buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with that
panels and cheese
get the top just as tasty as it is at
the bottom
my frittata needs three and a half to
four minutes under a red hot grill to
achieve the best results always ensure
your oven or grill are preheated to the
perfect temperature
she's ready
this is the thing i love about italian
cooking it's about sharing but always
focusing on the ingredients
look at that
that means incredible
a little shake the pan to make sure it
comes out and then spatula underneath
and just leave it
it's light
fluffy and it smells incredible
and that for me is a dream come true
it's amazing how far you can take six
eggs and two sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata my
ultimate italian breakfast
it's a cracking start to the day
[Music]
italian food puts a premium on fantastic
ingredients cooked simply
here's a bit of help on what to look for
when you're buying some of the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
for dinner tonight i'll be cooking value
for money beef cheek
this large meaty mussel can cost as
little as two pound of pop from your
local butcher
but the rewards of cooking it with a
little love and patience are bountiful
flash fried the meat from this hard
working muscle is very tough but slow
braising will transform it into four
falls of melt in your mouth
deliciousness i'll be using this cheeky
cut for a deliciously cheap italian
dinner that will feed a whole family
[Music]
burrata one of italy's most recent
cheesy exports was invented back in the
1920s from a need to make use of the
little scraps of mozzarella left in the
cheese making vat
these shreds are mixed with cream and
encased in a hand spun mozzarella pouch
this luxurious rich puglian delicacy is
now becoming more popular in our
supermarkets
[Music]
if i had to choose one herb synonymous
with italy
this would be it
basil
the perfect partner for tomato based
dishes or pounded with parmesan and pine
nuts for a delicious pesto
basil's soft silky aromatic leaves will
bring a taste of the mediterranean to
any dish they touch
and i'll be using it in my ultimate
italian lunch
in much of italy lunch is traditionally
seen as the most important meal of the
day and for a food obsessed nation
that's really saying something
whenever or whatever italians cook they
always put a premium on straightforward
fresh food prepared simply that's why
italian food is so brilliant for the
home cook
for my ultimate italian lunch i'm
cooking scrummy sardines topped with a
fragrant gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad
this is one of the hidden delicacies of
italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or
broth or minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice
but once they absorb that water they
double in size
it's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely a pinch of salt and
splash of extra virgin olive oil fresh
bay leaf
into the boiling water and that bay leaf
really helps to flavor the pasta give it
a little pan
a turn left and right that stops any
pasta sticking to the bottom and the
secret behind cooking any pasta is
having a nice gentle rolling boil you
just have the gas up where the outside
of the pan is just rolling and all that
also is tumbling over each other gently
boiling pasta rapidly tends to destroy
the outside texture it doesn't take the
marinade or the vinaigrette or the sauce
for the dressing parmesan twist of fresh
pepper the zest of the lemon
squeeze your lemon in there through your
fingers to catch all those seeds
bring that together with some extra
virgin olive oil
pine nuts taste delicious
toasting them just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
drain it a little bit of cold water
through it flows the cooking process
down but stops it from going mushy it's
the size of pumpkin seeds now
a drizzle of olive oil and into the
vinaigrette whilst it's still warm
just above room temperature
because the warmer the pasta the more it
absorbs the vinaigrette and now
some texture rocket not finely chopped
and the fresh basil as well
roll them up like a big fat cigar slice
in half
and then chop the basil
for crunch just sprinkle the toasted
pine nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels
glistens
is a delicious very fragrant orzo pasta
salad
now the sardines incredibly healthy and
absolutely delicious grilled never ever
be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish it's about the condition of
the fish bright eyes fresh gills nice
bright red interior and the firmness of
the flesh almost you could stand the
fish up on its own it needs to be that
fresh the best way to get flavour into a
sardine is to grill it
light seasoning
olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's a
little bit sharp push the rosemary in
almost like you're threading makes them
so much more flavoursome
they'll be scared those fine little
bones i remember growing up with
sardines tin sardines you didn't turn
your nose up with the bone
once the griddle pan starts to smoke
lightly drizzle and then sardines on
two and a half to three minutes each
side
now for the gremolata
a vinaigrette that sits beautifully well
on the sardines freshly parsley just run
the knife once there's nothing worse
when you overchop parsley and all that
delicious flavors left on the board
the zest and juice of an orange and a
lemon
i'm going to turn them now
gremolata is about fragrance
natural flavors
brilliant for grilled meat as well
a little touch of salt
and pepper
and then olive oil just to bring it
together
the garlic i almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
rate it
bring that together you've got a very
fresh
clean gremolata almost if we're sat on
the amalfi coast
off
and then whilst the sardines are still
nice and warm and just thinly
coat the gremolata
i'd like the path in the garlic to sit
on top and that's citrus from the lemon
and the orange to sort of dive
underneath
you can see why italian cuisine rides on
the freshest and the simplest execution
they allow their ingredients to become
the hero
not the chef
also salad
we're stunning grilled sardines
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the sea of
the mediterranean delicious
[Music]
one of the things i really admire about
the italian approach to food is not just
how they cook but how they eat and enjoy
food too
it's very very relaxed and it's all
about sharing great food with friends
and family our home life is pretty
hectic so when we're all at home
together we try and have a bit of
italian spirit at meal time
cheers now right my ultimate italian
dinner
[Music]
this is one of the kids favorites
and i've got jack helping me in the
kitchen
wow
[Music]
we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig jam crostini with
creamy barata
and the heart in maine are beef cheek
ragu with papla deli
beef cheeks just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
i want you to give them a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please so beef cheeks very cheap i cut
that takes sort of a long time to cook
yeah but give it a bit of love let it
cook in the oven
it comes out like a dream
a little touch of oil in the pan what we
want to do
is get them really nicely colored shade
see it into the pan
oh cool
layer wave
see what that is um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
the beach
beach
and then i want the onion chunky because
i'm gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
down
and then again there
and there so it doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half of six seven
o'clock in the morning three and a half
four hours to be ready for lunch and the
longer you leave them in their juices
yeah and the cooking liquor the better
three nice cloves of garlic good onions
in and garlic in please
nice where's your baby there it is good
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the
cheeks back in please
right red wine in cool okay and the red
wine is going to deglaze the pan so
delays will basically sort of
rinse
all that flavor off the bottom of the
pan yeah okay because that's going to
make the most amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better
i'm gonna top that with some stock so
the secret braising is having little of
the meat exposed and ninety percent of
it submerged see them there yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water
turn the gas off and leave the lid
just off at the end there if we had to
cover it completely
the steam hits the top yeah the lid and
all that water comes right back in solar
still that's right in the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
boom
for pudding i'm making one of my
absolute favorite italian desserts
banacotta with that quintessentially
italian flavoring espresso
[Music]
start by immersing two leaves of
gelatine in cold water and leave to soak
[Music]
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream
milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
[Music]
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
squeeze out the soaked gelatine leaves
and stir into the hot cream until
completely dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your moulds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel dust with ground cinnamon and
leave to set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm giving
each mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
[Music]
dress with a shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right captain jack quick run through
panna cotta's are nearly set beef cheeks
are nearly cooked we're gonna now do the
fig and crostini oh okay let's take the
figs we're gonna make a nice slightly
spicy
fig jam
take all the tops yeah in half and each
half into three
sugar the touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want to be too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah
what's the shape
stars star niche star on these taken
from the hennessy plant yeah when you
dry them like that so intensifies the
flavor really important to count how we
put in there okay yeah so one two three
four five so they're just there for a
flavor and then you take them out that's
right
secret here let's get that camera going
so when i hear of jam i don't think of
caramel
no but this is a very fast jam caramel's
starting to color
i want you very carefully to drop
the fig's in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the caramel
you know what that is oh sweet vanilla i
love that on my salad you've got that
sort of sweet and sour flavor leave that
cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice our chipotle in italian
crostini means little bits of toast
but it can be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread
we're staying authentically italian with
ciabatta
season them
and then drizzle
a little touch of olive oil on there
both sides really important because
we're going to grill the bread push it
down
put some lovely very lovely take it off
with the chipata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star in these pods
from our piping hot fig jam
my jacket we've got one little bugger to
fire oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
some of the skin's disintegrated in that
camel that looks so nice
while jack carefully spreads the
crostini with our hot fig jam i can
unveil the last element to our starter
the creamy italian speciality burrata
[Music]
money bags
they can delicious
this looks fun doesn't it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest can you imagine that sat
there
and you test all that off when you stick
it on top of that
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks i've chosen to use
papridelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salting first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it
nice bring that back up the bowl that's
gonna take about three
or four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait do you see
these beef cheeks
beauties
look at them
oh look
they're very soft tiny to taste
hmm
that's so good
oh jack you've just dribbled on your
jumper
joke
[Music]
really
right drain
the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
a little drizzle
of olive oil
and i want to put your fresh pasta
nicely chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
and you put
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
uh what about when you cook this with
your girlfriend one day
uh just tell her where you got the
recipe from william promise promise i
don't want you stealing daddy's thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there
two beautiful jaws on there
and then the third
jaw and then you go over
with the sauce
how cool is that delicious
you've got the
porrasa i've got the cheeks
let's go please
don't be cheeky
get it
my ultimate italian dinner quick thick
jam crostini with creamy borata
a main course of slow cooked beef cheek
ragu with papadely
and for pudding espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best italian
tradition
tilly
hey
we've got some cheeks for you
who would like to hold them in half
[Music]
tilly what's your favorite part i really
like the
cheeks
[Music]
not funny it's when somebody grabs the
other cheek start worrying well the
right one
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you